Jordan are we in a computer simulation
[Laughter]
if we are it's within a computer that we
don't understand but I look I said
questions like that are strange because
welcome to simulation no it's like it's
it's like asking whether you can reduce
consciousness to material to to its
material substrate and after that is yes
but by the time we reduce consciousness
to its material substrate our
understanding of what that material
substrate is will have transformed so
dramatically that it won't look very
much like the material substrate that we
presume now and so if we're in a
simulation then it's within the confines
of a mechanism that we can't easily
assimilate to our own computational
devices so it's it's it and then of
course the other problem with question
like that is well we've already defined
this as reality and so is reality a
simulation it's well know by definition
it's not it's you might say well a
simulation can get so real that you
can't distinguish it from reality but
you start almost all questions of the
form is a B
devolve down to it depends on how you
define a and B has the problem with
questions like that is a decontextualize
as the terms right it's like well what
do you mean by reality what do you mean
by simulation well if you mean the same
thing by both of them then they're the
same thing if you mean different things
by both of them then they're different
things and so well but I'm serious if
you have serious about that you know
[Applause]
well most of the time you can't pull
single terms out of a conversational
stream and assume that the term has a
bounded definition that's self-evident
using only that term because when we
converse it's like well you utter a
stream of words it's like well what are
the words mean well it depends on where
they are in the phrase it depends on
where they are in the sentence it
depends on where the sentence is located
in the paragraph it depends on the
context within which the paragraph is
uttered and you you triangulate all of
that simultaneously to extract out the
meaning of the word and then if you take
a word out like it's a thing and another
word out like it's a thing and you say
are these two things the same you're
acting as if those words can be
decontextualized and they have absolute
meaning and in their decontextualized
state and they don't so so so usually
those questions I would say in some
sense are philosophically are
philosophically untenable so
that's the answer that's what it is